en estos vídeos hemos estado hablando de
cómo se puede financiar una empresa que
se va a dedicar a vender calcetines por
internet y ya vimos varias cosas verdad
todo empezó con una idea y con cierto
talento que teníamos unos amigos y yo y
luego pasamos a empezar a financiar la
empresa por medio de un inversionista
ante el inversionista ángel dijo ah pues
esta idea y el talento vale 5 millones
yo voy a poner 5 millones de pesos en
efectivo para empezar a hacer todas las
contrataciones para empezar a realizar
el sitio de internet y con ese dinero ya
empezamos a trabajar
pasaron nos digamos déjame ponerle que
pasaron seis meses seis meses
y después de ese tiempo
llegamos a una hoja de balance de este
estilo en el cual ya nos gastamos un
poco del efectivo pero ya teníamos una
oficina un sitio de internet con un poco
de suerte una cartera de clientes
razonables hasta mesita de futbolito
teníamos vale entonces habíamos empezado
a gastar el efectivo ya nada más nos
quedaba un millón y pues era momento de
empezar a buscar más financiamiento
porque pues estaría muy feo que ya
después de haber trabajado tanto
tuviéramos que cerrar la empresa por no
poder pagar salarios o por no poder
realizar algún pedido importante o lo
que fuera
de este modo dijimos bueno ya éste
tenemos todo esto de acá se nos está
acabando el efectivo tenemos que
recurrir a un capitalista de riesgo
semilla y empezamos a practicar un poco
de cómo funcionaba esto de los
capitalistas de riesgo los capitalistas
de riesgo ya profesionales dijimos que
eran personas con las cuales será un
poco más difícil de negociar porque eran
pues más expertos manejaban dinero de
otras personas a través de fondos de
cobertura o cosas por el estilo y
entonces ellos ya éste se enfocaban en
hacer un muy buen análisis de nuestra
empresa y pues el chiste era intentar
convencer a uno de ellos entonces
supongamos que ya vamos y le platicamos
a varios capitalistas de riesgo la idea
de vender calcetines por internet unos
no cierran la puerta pero de repente hay
uno que dice si sabes que a mí me
mientras me entusiasman mucho los
calcetines así que los voy a apoyar para
apoyarnos va a tener que hacer un
análisis previo otra vez entonces dentro
de nuestra serie a
déjame ponerle aquí la serie que es esta
primera ronda con un capitalista experto
vamos a tener una vez más una
preevaluación voy a ponerle por aquí
si no va pre evaluación o sea otra vez
una evaluación previa de cuánto se
supone que vale nuestra empresa ok
entonces una vez más él va a decir bueno
voy a poner a mis analistas a investigar
el capitalista de riesgo pues p o sea
como que su idea detrás es después
invertir en ciertos negocios y puede ser
que diez de ellos o sea de diez que
invierta pues nueve no valgan nada o
tengan una alta probabilidad de no vale
o nada pero con que con uno con que le
peguen que tenga así un muy buen
rendimiento que de repente la empresa
valga miles de millones pues ya la hacen
para el dinero de sus clientes entonces
pues tienen que investigar bien su
mercado tienen que empezar a buscar cómo
está el negocio y cómo está con respecto
a competidores entonces supongamos que
el capitalista de riesgo que nos va a
apoyar empieza a ser un análisis se mete
en el mercado de la ropa interior por
internet y entonces se da cuenta que
pues hay otros competidores y que ha
habido otras evaluaciones y que empresas
similares a la nuestra pero de ropa
interior así de todo tipo se les ha dado
una evaluación de pues no sé déjame
decir de unos 20 ó 30 millones
como 20 o 30 estas son empresas
similares
y entonces ya le pide a sus analistas
que hagan gráficas que calculen retorno
sobre la inversión y llegan a la
conclusión de que todo esto de acá de
que nuestra empresa debería de valer
déjame ponerle un buen número 15
millones de pesos o sea lo mejor no 20 ó
30 porque 20 ó 30 y además ropa interior
de calzones y de camisetas pero como
nosotros sólo vendemos calcetines nos
dando una preparación de 15 millones
nosotros decimos va a estar muy bien
estos son muy buenas noticias verdad
porque estamos creando valor antes acá
arriba nuestra empresa según nosotros
valía 10 millones pero ahorita este
experto en inversiones ya nos está
diciendo que vale 15 millones entonces
esto está padre para el inversionista
ángel porque hace sentir que hizo una
buena inversión y eso es una indicación
para nosotros de seguir trabajando con
muchas ganas porque logramos crear valor
entonces ya el capitalista de riesgo
hace la preevaluación nos dice que es de
15 millones y nos dice ok cuánto dinero
necesita supongamos que nosotros vemos
hacemos nuestras cuentas y decimos que
necesitamos otros 7.5 millones de pesos
vale millones de pesos a esta y con este
efectivo ya vamos a poder pues pagar un
poco más en comerciales a lo mejor
incluso meter uno en la final de fútbol
y vamos a poder contratar un poco más de
personas para que le den seguimiento a
las órdenes y lo que sea y entonces el
capitalista de riesgo de cebada me
parece muy bien tu plan muy bueno tu
plan entonces voy a colaborar te con
esos 7.5 millones de pesos entonces qué
sucedería
aquí tendríamos ahora los 7.5 millones
de pesos del capitalista de riesgo
entonces éste ya sería efectivo con el
cual podemos trabajar y a cambio el
capitalista de riesgo va a necesitar ser
parte
de nuestra sociedad de nuestra empresa
entonces vamos a tener que una vez más
que emitir acciones ahora quienes están
en la mesa directiva pues estamos
nosotros los fundadores y está el
inversionista ángel bueno a lo mejor no
está así de entrada pero como ya compro
tantas acciones pues puede ponerse en la
mesa directiva porque los accionistas
son los que eligen quienes quedan en
esta posición
entonces ya entre todos nosotros los
fundadores y el ángel decidimos emitir
acciones y como ya todos habíamos
quedado de acuerdo con la preevaluación
con la preevaluación de estar acá verdad
la de 15 millones para poner aquí 15
millones como ahora nos está colaborando
con 7.5 millones vamos a tener que darle
acciones correspondientes hasta ahorita
nosotros teníamos en total 2 millones
pero 2 millones es a 15 millones como un
millón y esas 7.5 verdades 37.5 es la
mitad de 15-1 es la mitad de 2 entonces
vamos a emitir le a este capitalista un
millón de acciones muy bien cómo están
las cosas hasta ahorita en porcentajes
este capitalista tiene un tercio de la
empresa e inversionista ángel también y
nosotros también tenemos un tercio los
fundadores en total que es
aproximadamente igual a 33.3 por ciento
aquí igual
33.3 por ciento y aquí abajo
éste también es 33.3 por ciento pero
esta parte morada que es de uno de
nosotros digamos mía es aproximadamente
como del 6% diarios más o menos una
quinta parte tantito más
de 6 % ok entonces así están las
situaciones en ese momento nos da el
dinero seguimos trabajando vamos a
ponerle que pasan otros seis meses
seis meses
ya logramos trabajar muy bien le echamos
las ganas ahora ya tenemos presencia en
latinoamérica tenemos los mejores
diseñadores italianos de calcetines y
está empezando a meterse francia en esto
también entonces seis meses después ya
pues tenemos una nueva hoja de balance
la voy a poner aquí abajo déjenme
moverme un poco más entonces en esta
nueva hoja de balance
vamos a tener
varios activos verdad parte de los
activos que vamos a tener ese efectivo
pero supongamos que como ya trabajamos
tanto otra vez estamos justo en la línea
otra vez ya nada más nos queda un millón
de pesos en efectivo en efectivo le voy
a poner pero todo lo demás pues no te
tiró a la basura ahora ya tenemos un
montón de cosas más interesantes que
podemos ofrecer como una buena cartera
de clientes
cartera tenemos presencia internacional
presencia ahora tenemos una marca
importante
a lo mejor pues ya contratamos el
dominio calcetines en línea puntocom y
no no sé si existe bueno si existe
perdón sí si los ofendo pero ya tenemos
un montón de cosas bien padres con las
cuales podemos seguir haciendo nuestro
trabajo pero como nuestra empresa ha
crecido tanto estamos apenas en el
límite en el cual pues sí entre que sí y
no podemos generar nuestro propio
efectivo para pagar este nuestros gastos
entonces otra vez tenemos que recurrir a
otra ronda de financiamiento antes de
eso déjame dibujar por acá él
el capital voy a dibujar aquí las tres
partes por aquí está lo del
inversionista ángel de este lado estamos
los fundadores fundadores y aquí arriba
tenemos el de la serie a
de la serie para entonces esta es la
estructura de capital hasta ahorita
estoy acá son nuestros activos se nos
está acabando el dinero y ya casi casi
vamos a poder generar nuestro propio
este ingreso sólo que necesitamos
recurrir a una ronda más entonces ahora
vamos a pasar a la serie a la serie b y
en esta ocasión ya no vamos a recurrir
pues a un capitalista de riesgo semilla
porque ya que somos una empresa más o
menos grande y mucho menos a un
inversionista de ángel ahora tenemos que
enfocarnos en otro tipo de capital ahora
vamos a ir con el capital de riesgo de
rendimiento este rendimiento es una
forma de decirle básicamente es ahora un
capitalista que justo está enfocado o
con es un tipo de capital que justo está
enfocado en ayudar a las empresas a
cruzar la línea de la
autosustentabilidad vale entonces vamos
platicamos con varios una vez más pues
hay varios que nos rechazan pero de
repente llegamos con uno que nos dice ok
yo soy fanático de los calcetines pero
también son muy soy muy bueno en los
negocios mis analistas confían en
ustedes vamos a financiar entonces
llegamos con este capitalista de riesgo
capitalista de riesgo de rendimiento nos
dice todo está muy bien vamos a hacer
una evaluación de su empresa a ver cómo
van y vamos a ser optimistas y vamos a
suponer que una vez más nos toca una
ronda hacia arriba déjame escribirle por
aquí ronda ronda hacia arriba no te
platicado de esto verdad pueden existir
rondas hacia arriba y rondas hacia abajo
qué quiere decir esto una ronda hacia
arriba es una ronda en la cual la
evaluación nueva es mayor que la
evaluación posterior de la etapa pasada
entonces en este caso quería decir que
va a evaluar la empresa en más de estos
este pues 15 7.5 o sea de estos 22
puntos 5 millones de pesos puede haber o
sea una mira estoy acá fue ronda hacia
arriba verdad porque cuando pasamos del
inversionista ángel a la serie a
nosotros pensábamos que valía 10
millones al final de esta ronda pero
capitalista semilla dijo que valía 15
millones eso fue muy bueno pasamos de 5
pesos por acción a 7.5 pesos por acción
que no sé de dónde quedó esto pero bueno
y luego acá abajo este supongamos que
también va a pasar eso entonces bueno
vamos a ponerle por acá en la
preevaluación y supongamos que que está
inversionista que el de la serie debe
nos dice los apoyos y además creo que su
empresa vale 30 millones 30 millones de
pesos esto estaría fantástico porque
mira cómo están las cuentas hasta
ahorita acá arriba acá arriba teníamos
un precio por acción de 5 millones luego
cuando pasamos a la seriedad teníamos 15
millones divididos en 2 millones de
acciones entonces teníamos un precio por
acción de 7 pesos
con 50 centavos entonces ya aumento en
50% y luego cuando pasamos a esta ronda
a la serie b la evaluación nos dice que
nuestras acciones valen 10 pesos cada
una eso está fantástico para todos
nosotros verdad muy bien entonces ya que
acordamos que las acciones valen 10
pesos
este capitalista de riesgo va a decir
bueno cuánto necesitan vamos a suponer
que necesitamos le voy a poner acá
arriba
que necesitamos otros 10 millones y que
si nos los da 10 millones de pesos y
puede saber cómo estarían las cosas
ahorita aquí tenemos 3 millones de
acciones correspondientes a 30 millones
de pesos si pone otros 10 millones
tendríamos que emitir otro millón de
acciones muy bien entonces ahora sí ya
tenemos un financiamiento muy serio con
esto hoy ojalá ya podemos llegar a una
apuesta tener una empresa muy grande que
pueda ser autosustentable
pero pero bueno podríamos seguir
haciendo más rondas de financiamiento
pero hay un paso muy grande que es hacer
una oferta pública primaria el de esto
vamos a hablar en el siguiente vídeo que
tiene que ver con la bolsa mexicana de
valores con la bolsa mexicana de valores
y esto es irse así a lo grande bueno nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo y hasta la
próxima